10 15 years ago kevin simon was not
nothing special guys were more rooted in
that they were more upfront than that
they were more like do you know what i
mean they were more
misogynist in
quotes all right so even
i got a question like that so are you
saying that men nowadays
are more feminine oh 100 percent
yes i don't really percentage very much
let a lady say ladies like yes yes all
right why are men more feminine
oh you want me to go yeah
um i feel like as time goes on i guess i
feel like guys have been more able to
express their feelings more so because
in the past you see a guy crying and
that was taboo like guys don't cry like
what are you crying for like you're
supposed to be strong you're supposed to
be a man men don't cry now you see guys
crying now you see guys more in touch
with their feelings saying
what they want out of relationships to
women or taking on those roles and i
feel like it's been kind of like a shift
like women are becoming more masculine
and
as you see more women being independent
and stuff like that it's like oh they
get labeled as aggressive and other
things and it's like the tables have
turned a little bit and then maybe
that's what's bringing up some of these
guys and being angry because there's
some i feel like some of the guys that
are angry are not
as feminine
i mean but like isn't that what you guys
want by
equality because like equality is to
meet in the middle it's like if if
you're becoming more masculine we're
becoming more feminine we're coming
closer to the center like isn't that
what you want like you know that kind of
off guard they don't want that
one they they think they want that but
that's not actually what they want yeah
like i'll tell you why
your your friend in the friend zone is
feminine like you know i mean you don't
want you you know what i'm saying you
don't want your friend's own guy you
want the guy that you you know what i
mean you it's like why is a guy in the
friend zone feminine that's because i
don't think the friend zone exists
okay i tell you why i exist
it's just a friendship it's a friendship
but a man and a woman can't be friends
like that
actually they can't approach this hang
on wait wait
you were saying why is that a bad thing
that men are becoming more is that what
you're saying
what we um
i think um you said something about
coming together like close like um men
being
more more feminine and wouldn't be wrong
i think that's like a good thing because
you men didn't want the struggle of not
to struggle even though
it is but the pressure of providing and
protecting like surely it's a good thing
women women aren't attracted to uh
feminine men who are like i don't know
guys
women are attracted to feminine men
i am i think if what's wrong what's
wrong with feminine like being in touch
with your generally
generally women are not attractive
they're associated with feminine traits
but it doesn't make a man girly so
you're still a man so that guy so that
like i said that guy that you're
attracted to that feminine man if like
uh my brother over here was saying um
there's a burglar in the house and he's
like oh my god baby go and deal with the
bad guys is that okay with you but
you're like
that's that's definitely a stereotype
is that a feminine man or what if he
what if he made you fight what if he
made you fight instead of him
well if i do karate or mutai or
something maybe it's better i go
this is uh your mute can only go so fast
because strength
years yeah i 130 get your point
i'm just saying that i don't think it's
a bad thing that men are becoming more
feminine and women are becoming more
masculine it just makes you more human
we have both energies running through
your your
your masculine and feminine in one
here's what i've got to say about that
what makes me mass masculine is what
you're attracted to and what you're like
okay okay
me being masculine is me
if you get what i'm trying to say if i'm
if i'm being something that you're not
attracted to that or that you're not
then you're not gonna like me but you're
masculi you can be masculine that's fine
but i'm saying there are some men that
are masculine but they also are more in
touch with their feminine side and
there's nothing wrong with that oh no no
there's not there's nothing wrong with
that yeah we're not talking about what
what about feminine men yeah we're
talking about feminine men in terms of
should all men be like more feminine
like i i think that if you're if you're
a feminist how do you define feminine
if god acts like a goal he becomes a pig
me right how do you define a feminine
man
well it's kind of like okay
like meaning
he cares more about his parents than you
um he spends more time in the bathroom
he's got all of these nice oils he likes
to give himself a camera very emotional
a little very easy he's over emotional
yeah um
um he's he's ruled but as a matter of
fact ruled by his emotions yes
um women don't like men like this okay
women like men to be to know what they
want to do to get it done
and they can talk about it afterwards so
to me
like looking at love island all of those
men are exactly like that yeah like and
that was saying i have men become more
feminine nowadays like i think they're
exactly like that yeah so
when you say feminine you mean about
appearance not about emotional
appearance
the lack of testosterone in their bodies
i'm talking about um how they speak how
they're around women how they're around
other men
feminine men like
bro like no backbone bro like
you you you're very agreeable you don't
like
um tension you don't like confrontation
a lot of traits that men have make them
three
where they are do you know what i mean
it's like i'm a boss because i am not
easily agreeable yeah and also like i'm
a boss because i i i'm i'm like stern
that necessarily isn't alpha like you
see a feminine man is just not an alpha
man and that is people women just want
alpha men i'll be rude
that percentage of men that women are
looking for are alpha men what what
people what classes are for me
um
sorry go on yeah but i feel like alpha
men and things like nature do not exist
because like if you're trying to be an
alpha you're forcing yourself to do it
like bro do you know someone in in like
your college or something that gets all
the girls yeah but like no no no
you know someone right you know the guy
that you see and you think
like a next one yeah another gal yeah
yeah you know you see you know you know
the guy yeah but like don't pretend like
you don't know who he is or you're
ignoring who he is because i feel like
you tried to be like him or you tried to
act like him or you tried to do his you
have his traits or you no i feel like
someone's trying to like sell a
blueprint like there is people that are
naturally like that but i feel like
because we're all unique and things like
nature like no one can be like one
version of an alpha like but because
there's like this blueprint that's out
there like oh if you're an alpha you
have to be providing you have to be
strong you have to be six foot you have
to be an alpha is strong because you're
a leader like you're taking the lead
yeah but anyone can take the league it's
just do you have the courage to stand up
and take anyone can't take the lead
because if that was the case everyone
would be leaders yeah exactly but that's
only because you let yourself follow
someone else and that's why you never
have an opportunity to be the leader no
you're either alpha or not like it
doesn't matter if someone's gonna give
me that opportunity i'm gonna take it
i'm gonna take it if i'm if i'm the
strong person if i'm the biggest person
i'm going to go for it doesn't matter if
you want me to have it or not i'm going
for it because in that sense i would be
the alpha like the alpha is always going
to be the strongest person you could be
strong but you might not be smart
and that's the issue
okay you're misunderstanding the terms
alpha when i use it like there's a
difference between like the alpha guy or
the high value guy like if you bring
value to a woman
like
it's hard like me bringing value to you
is not me being an alpha me bringing
value to my woman is me being an alpha
women see this like it's like certain
girls they would look at guys that have
kids and see how they treat their kids
and be like oh yeah yeah i mean that
that's an attraction woman like some
women they'll be like okay i see okay
i've seen him in the in the office i've
seen how he is how he controls the room
among other people i like that a man is
not necessarily like that a man is more
like oh she's look at that
you know what i'm saying she done her
hair that night all right say no more
all right she's walking i'm not really
looking for her like traits in terms of
masculine traits i'm looking for her
feminine traits so that's what i mean
when i say like
how you being an alpha woman
is you being a lonely woman
because like yeah being a masculine
woman normally leads to loneliness yeah
i mean someone might like them but it's
just normal yeah but that would be the
exception i i have to agree with what
you're saying like women who find
themselves trying to outdo men in a
masculinity department seldom find a
long-term partner because men generally
want feminine women and a lot of women
nowadays have become quite masculine
the men become quite feminine
and so
you know like i said that's one of the
reasons why i guess red pill rage men
are kind they're kind of missing
people like kevin samuels people like
the red pill community gave men
their
masculinity back to some degree because
i felt i think they felt like they were
losing it
i feel i think men felt like they were
losing their masculinity they were being
told that their masculinity is
misogynistic it was toxic all of this
kind of stuff